welcome back to Petersburg without
censor controversial influencer Andrew
Tate's uncensored return last night to
be viewed over a million times so far on
YouTube alone his fans call him a
misunderstood Maestro of masculinity his
critics say he's a malignant malicious
misogynist I think he's probably
somewhere between the two but last night
once again he divided opinion
I do mean what I say if I were to see a
girl on a private plane on Instagram for
example I would assume that a man put
her on that private plane I would not
assume she bought it herself what if it
was perhaps that makes me misogynistic
what about the Afghan women it's nothing
to do with me on any level you don't
have a view I have a view my view is
that people naturally gravitate towards
Law and Order and if you didn't have the
Taliban you'd have different Warlords
operating in lawlessness and there would
be no way to prevent your store or your
Market stall getting completely robbed
by someone with an AK-47 and people are
going to gravitate towards a form of Law
and Order America left they left a power
vacuum and the power vacuum is now full
what about their treatment of women only
tonight only tonight they have banned
any women from going to University
fantastic let's get the feminists to go
and teach them a lesson the feminists
are so tough and they stand up and say
they can do anything a man can do let's
arm them up and send them to Afghanistan
I'm sure they'll fix it why can't you
just say on that you know what it's
completely wrong because it's not my
point it's I don't understand it makes
me think it'll make your critics think
that you don't think it's wrong they
could ban all men they could ban all
sure then no are there any Banning
movements correct they could ban all
short people they could ban all people
with long hair and not if it's anything
to do with me so they can do whatever
they want I'm not going to go to war
with the Taliban do you think you're a
misogynist absolutely not I'm not a
misogynist on any level this is one of
those buzzwords they throw it and they
just throw at people randomly homophobic
racist misogynistics throw it out at
people
what joining me now is talkatively
contribute to Esther kraku and a
trembling broadcaster and journalist
Jenny Cleveland visibly recoiling in
Horrors let's start with you Jenny
um he's not your idea of a role model
well no he's not I I see him as a
symptom of a problem rather than a
solution to it I can understand what's
the problem that he's the symptom the
problem is that I think a lot of young
men uh feel that nobody is speaking up
for them in their culture where we are
encouraged to have identity Politics the
only identity that isn't a good identity
is a young man or a young white male he
talks in a very straight way and he
gives straight answers to uh some
questions which I think he gives very
wrong answers to
um but I find him repellent I think he
he talks about he talks he basically
creates Straw Men that he destroys so he
will uh depict feminism as a particular
kind of thing a kind of man-hating thing
which it isn't well it is for some
feminists for a small number of families
I mean there are some radical feminism
definitely are there definitely are but
most people know that feminism is about
just thinking that everyone should have
equal opportunities regardless of yeah
and one thing we know from Afghanistan
these heartbreaking scenes today in
Afghanistan of weeping female students
who couldn't go to university and Men
actually in Afghanistan then going out
in protest for them
[Music]
[Music]
these young women in Afghanistan weeping
because they've been told they cannot
now continue their education and then
you've got male students walking out in
practice very brave thing to do bit like
we saw in Iran with the men protesting
in support of the women being oppressed
there this is where he slightly lost me
last night Andrew there are a lot of
things he says which I understand why
young men you feel a bit lost why they
gravitate to his confidence he's very
good at building business he's proven
he's made himself extremely rich doing
it a lot of what he says about
masculinity and stuff I I completely
would sign up to actually yeah and these
confidence can help people but when he
was not prepared to condemn
barbarians for that yeah because that to
me is an open and shut case if you don't
condemn it then I'm afraid you've got a
problem and it's not about sending
feminist in to go to war as I pointed
out actually do you think it's a valid
point well a lot of women do actually
fight in the armed forces yeah so I
think
is also nonsense I think he was using
that to kind of attack the more extreme
forms of feminism which that says you
know women can do anything a man can do
and he was using that as an example but
I do think you know you lose people when
you refuse to outright condemn sort of
10th Century barbarians like this um but
I I don't think when you said it has
nothing to do with him I think he's not
willing to get into dicey territory in
that way but it's like you speak in such
absolute terms why do you think he's a
misogynist I don't think he's a
misogynist no I don't think massages
means somebody who hates women I don't
think he hates women I think he thinks
women are nothing I think he would not
know what to do with you and I Esther
because he does not know how to deal he
gives interviews to people like you or
to Hugo Rifkin he'll give interviews a
lot of women I've spoken to about it but
other women he's done interviews with
women I've seen them for
yeah women do a lot of women do like him
exactly there are a lot of women who
don't know him who seem to hate him
ironically um but I'm not sure this is
clear he's a misogynist I don't think
he's a misogynist and I have a brother
who's probably within his Target
demographic 23 and I can understand why
his message would resonate with him
because
it's normal exactly for young men to
feel like they don't have a place in
Western society and he actually made
that point I just think when you don't
want to outright condemn 10th Century
barbarians like the Taliban you tend to
lose your case with more moderate people
but again well not his Target or the
fact that his his understanding about
what's happening in Afghanistan is that
it's a feminist issue rather than a
human I don't think he said that well no
he did he said send this feminist in
it's a human issue where we made all
these promises to people in Afghanistan
and then we left well let's be clear we
betrayed those words we absolutely
in the way we pulled out of Afghanistan
overnight and we betrayed not only
people who work with us the interpreters
and so on but people are millions
millions of Afghan women yeah I've just
been tossed back to these barriers who
died for it but the fact that that he
sees it he says oh it's got nothing to
do with me as a human being it should
have something to do as someone who says
no I agree I thought he was a cop out
there but albeit again a lot of what he
says I could imagine if I was a young
man it would resonate with me probably
for the right reasons because he's
trying to give people confidence and a
belief that being masculine is not
actually a stick to beat you with right
you can be a good masculine person he
used to be appalled
um let's talk to somebody I don't think
is a shining example of this Joe likes
it who has spent the last month
posturing away with his shiny moral Halo
about David Beckham being in Qatar and
representing the qataris in the world
cup and being paid for it
um and then the sun revealed yesterday a
rather uncomfortable truth which is that
he had actually performed himself in
Qatar Abu Dhabi and Dubai in 2015 a
series of stand-up gigs for money Esther
now there's a word for this and I call
it hypocrisy well this is the thing it's
hypocrisy and it's cowardice because he
would say these things but he wouldn't
actually go to Qatar on and sit on Qatar
State television and say all these
things he can sit back comfortably and
rage out there but his whole point was
David Beckham shouldn't be there and
shouldn't be fronting anything for the
qataris when this guy himself has taken
it and his excuse was so mealy mouiled
Jenny oops I've been caught by the sun
well yes I did two gigs in Doha actually
it was three gigs in Dubai Abu Dhabi and
Qatar I kept it secret by writing about
it in my own book well no one remembers
that from seven years ago
um like it was paid a few hundred quid
not keen to say exactly how much not by
Qatar but my UK company promoters who
were being paid by Qatar but it was 2015
when qatar's laws were exactly the same
about homosexuality as they are today
and that went a lot further back then
and so he goes on and then he says no no
but who should I take more lectures from
not from the Sun okay what about Siri
it's not about the sun here it's about
Joe likes its hypocrisy I think it
doesn't look good for Jay lice it but I
would say that they're different things
the World Cup is about giving soft power
on the
gay comedians going to a country which
they profess to hate because
they are they're by going there they are
basically saying I don't care I'm
pocketing the money it's the same
argument he used against Becca I think
with Beckham it's to do with being an
ambassador on the global stage for a
country that is trying to elevate their
profile Joe likes it in 20 minutes
when he said he was drunk one night he
said Madam would you sleep with me for a
million pounds and she said would you be
for a million pounds did you go well I
don't know Winston and he said uh well
would you send me for a pound no don't
be outrageous well look we already
established what kind of woman do you
think you have we know what kind of
woman you are we're haggling over the
price right that was a joke but my point
about Joe lie says he seems to be saying
I only take a few hundred Beckham took a
few a few million what's the difference
I think you have to be careful about
doing this kind of archeology about what
people have done really quite far in the
past
years ago when it was illegal to be gay
in Qatar
in Dubai and it was illegal to be gay in
the U.S once you sanctioned this kind of
stuff your sanction it's fair game for
anybody like all of those Sports people
who wear it which established when they
were 18 so 10 years ago stop buying it
rank hypocrite don't want us any more
Joe license moral Halo thanks thank you
Pat